what I do Gregg jonald we're gonna watch
the top reward to your video request
from Jason Dolan I'm excited for this
reading the title this comes from a
channel called kinky de spaghetti
western trailer for the man DeLorean
very cool
[Applause]
we were watching the mandalorian and
covering it here on YouTube with
reaction highlights full-length
reactions three belongs for the
mandalorian over at our patreon page
what's gonna shout this thing out again
hell yeah I AB we do a weekly Q&A s at
our patron up page we have shows a
reduced stream along sync up with the
timecode Ozark and Lorien agents of
shield and Gotham and there are other
shows that we cover there as well and
their shows where we have the stream
along option and reaction highlights
included for them and those shows are
supernatural Hunter hunter code geass
Death Note my hero academia movie
included attack on side and under some
other shows there that we do as well go
to our patreon page today to see if you
want to be a patreon at the patreon
pages we have a patreon bounty hunting
is a complicated process that it is
[Music]
you put a film grain on it or some just
like wow that is so cool I love the
clouds
[Music]
you
warmer colder coming with them energy
cannon
vibrating knife leymah sure like the
simple names electronic da haha damn
well done man well done I was wonderful
I would love to see a slight I mean that
you could really do much to it but you
can kind of tweak the audio to make it
sound a little bit more from that era oh
yeah you cut it out a sink a little bit
and made it a little lower fine yeah
yeah cuz nowadays audios like
exceptionally more crisp it's so heavily
like to have a little bit older audio
and maybe have some of that like film
grain and maybe change some of the sound
effects a bit you're gonna be that much
different but you know the things that
people like us would pick up on yeah
maybe add a few more like smash zooms
and then would pans yeah to match the
cinematography of the age but I mean
this lends itself really well to that
format I love the little ya additions
like the clouds and stuff especially
having gone to so many like New Beverly
screenings and seeing so many old
trailers played like this really was on
the money exactly and then even changing
the text having the changing the
language and then having the subtitles
for it but then even doing the tail at
the hill Mandalore and looks so
authentic yeah you know and it fits
appropriately considering that
Mandalorian is very spaghetti western
inspired enough as it is this is so cool
oh that was awesome Italian actor Pedro
Pascal it just enhances the appreciation
for for the Laura touch the show comes
from yeah exactly
damn that was awesome kinky dough what
kind of videos do you do damn you've
been around for a while the clunky fails
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
using my clunky I mean not if it's a
meme I mean I remember that character
from sorry oh you haven't heard about
this my clunky thing no this is noon
online a phenomenon I am unaware of I
can't be out of the loop these things
move so fast what's my clunky John you
were way out of the loop I'm sorry they
released Star Wars a new hope on Disney
Plus and George Lucas one and added this
little McClung kylo really it's just
like a well like a one moment yeah I
just had all this speculation now as to
like what the hell is my clunky yeah I
didn't know that at all but I'm really
happy that this happened I'm really glad
that we're still tinkering around the
hood of Star Wars and and and at least
people aren't upset at least it's a meme
I'm glad about that
Oh last time I want to say - I loved
simple titles for all the kind of
weapons and gadgets and also electronic
door yeah nicknaming
all of the characters he died cuz you
hear I had having the impression you're
just gonna do the good the bad the ugly
but he literally had a nickname for
everyone so great so awesome awesome
touches dude and I like your monkey
fails videos guys subscribe to King
Keita you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can click the notification
bell you could you should hit the like
button or dislike button I don't care
and Jason Dolan thank you dude now you
are so awesome I call Jason just a
couple weeks ago we chatted on the phone
for a long time he's got so much in
development right now is that so many
things he's getting off the ground
getting off you know what's funny though
mmm yeah that hit me up about being in
anything I'm a clunky he hasn't hit me
up about writing anything with him
clunky he hasn't sent me any nude pics
McClung key look he sends me a lot of
new pics
that's why I was not much it's dude like
I get at this point I just I know your
Anatomy it's confusing because look I
faked over John shoulder look at the
phone cuz Jason is all there he's bald
but then he also shaves his crotch and
sometimes I can't tell from looking at
Jason's head or his crotch
yeah there's impressive and it's also a
little scary there are times I've talked
to him and all I see are balls you've
never seen Jason Dylan's face actually
you've been talking to his lower half
this whole time sophisticated we thought
he was taller than I realize I'm on my
knees yeah it's just perspective man
yeah that's all clunky